hey Rob here with some more Balfron to  gameplay you're looking at some gorgeous  PC ultra settings footage flying around  as the Naboo Starfighter worth noting  battlefront 2 flight controls allow you  to roll left and right making for a far  more enjoyable experience if you want to  see more gameplay like this give us a  like and sub thanks for watching  [Music]  the empty cheese getting ready to fire  [Music]  no you stop in that empty tea now blast  it shouldn't come to this fallback  positions withdrawal palace we haven't  lost yet  all right we hold back those droids long  enough we can get reinforcements on the  sighting coordinates guard your  positions  [Music]  [Music]